hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing 10 more
dark moments from the books that were
either misrepresented in the films or
omitted entirely these were moments so
dark that in the case of some they had
to be removed in order to keep the
film's PG rating down I've also done a
part one and two so be sure to check
those out if you haven't already anyway
I won't dawdle let's dive in Harry
hearing his parents screaming throughout
the books Harry has copious encounters
with Dementors and one aspect of these
encounters that somewhat overlooked in
the films is that when he's in their
presence he's being exposed to the
screams of his dying parents expecto
patronum harryald expecto patronum
expecto but the classroom in the Demento
were dissolving Harry was falling again
through thick white fog and his mother's
voice was louder than ever echoing
inside his
not Harry not Harry please I'll do
anything stand aside stand aside girl
Harry white fog obscured his senses big
blood shapes were moving around him then
came a new voice a man's voice shouting
panicking Lily take Harry and go it's
him go run I'll hold him off the sounds
of someone stumbling from a room a door
bursting open a cackle of high-pitched
laughter Harry Harry wake up though
Harry also suffers in the presence of
Dementors in the films the specificity
of the books makes these experiences
that much darker
umbridge's torture of Harry in the Order
of the Phoenix we see Umbridge take
Hogwarts by storm by first becoming a
professor and later becoming
headmistress
and it's during the same school year
that she regularly abuses her power
particularly when it comes to student
punishments taking it upon herself to
instate highly torturous forms of
corporal punishment the best example of
this is when Umbridge gives Harry the
black quill a dark magical torture
device
while using this quill whatever the user
writes is carved onto the back of their
hand and the blood from the word sliced
into the hand is magically siphoned and
used as an ink on the parchment Harry
does use this same quill in the films
but on only one occasion it also feels
as though his detention is relatively
short-lived the books expand on this
further by emphasizing that Harry had
many detentions lasting hours and hours
sometimes starting at 5 pm and Lasting
until well over midnight
he let out a gasp of pain the words had
appeared on the parchment in what
appeared to be shining red ink at the
same time the words had appeared on the
back of Harry's right hand cut into his
skin as though traced there by a scalpel
yet even as he stared at The Shining
the skin healed over again leaving
the place where it had been slightly
redder than before but quite smooth he
looked back at the parchment placed the
quill upon it once more wrote I must not
tell lies and felt the Searing pain on
the back of his hand for a second time
once again the words had been cut into
his skin once again they healed over
seconds later and on it went again and
again Harry wrote the words on the
parchment in what he soon came to
realize was not ink but his own blood
and again and again the words were cut
into the back of his hand healed and
then reappeared the next time he set
quill to parchment
Harry undergoes so much torturous
punishment that he eventually develops a
scar on his hand reading I must not tell
lies Harry's Breaking Point Harry
endures a lot over the course of the
story but it isn't always properly
addressed in the films the books do a
much better job of this and in one
particular moment we witness Harry reach
his absolute breaking point during
Harry's time at school he personally
Witnesses the murder of a fellow student
and friend he has to cope with the rise
of Voldemort the same dark wizard that
murdered his parents
he has to go back to privet Drive every
summer and suffer the aftermath of his
tragic years away at school all by
himself every attempt he makes to help
with the Brewing war is rejected or
dismantled and he's mocked and called a
liar by The Wizarding publication the
daily prophet and these are only some of
the things he has to deal with at the
tender age of 15. Harry turned his back
on Dumbledore instead determinedly out
of the opposite window he could see the
Quidditch stadium in the distance Sirius
had appeared there once disguised as the
shacky black dog so he could watch Harry
play he had probably come to see where
the Harry was as good as James had been
Harry had never asked him there is no
shame in what you're feeling Harry said
Dumbledore's voice on the contrary the
fact that you can feel pain like this is
your greatest strength Harry felt the
white hot anger lick his insides blazing
in the terrible emptiness filling him
with the desire to hurt Dumbledore for
his calmness and his empty words my
greatest strength visit said Harry his
voice shaking as he stared out at the
Quidditch Stadium no longer seeing it
you haven't got a clue you don't know
what don't I know asked Dumbledore
calmly it was too much Harry turned
around shaking with rage I don't want to
talk about how I feel all right Harry
suffering like this proves you are still
a man this pain is part of Being Human
then I don't want to be human Harry
roared and he seized one of the delicate
silver instruments from the
spindle-legged table beside him and
flung it across the room it shattered
into a hundred tiny pieces against the
wall several of the pictures let out
yells of anger and fright and the
portrait of Armando Tippett said really
I don't care Harry yelled at them
snatching up a Luna scope and throwing
it into the fireplace I've had enough
I've seen enough I want out I want it to
end I don't care anymore the films did a
lot of things well but the pain that
Harry experiences in this moment is only
appropriately encapsulated in the novels
Harry's ghostly realization this next
dark moment comes after the breakdown
mentioned above at the end of Order of
the Phoenix after a hell of a rough
school year Harry seems to find solace
in the idea that he may one day be
reunited with Sirius when he returned to
the land of the living as a ghost in
this moment Harry has a glimmer of hope
in his heart for the first time in a
while however he has later gently
disabused by nearly headless Nick who
explains to Harry how the whole ghost
thing actually works after their
exchange Harry has to face the harsh
reality that Sirius is well and truly
gone oh very well he Nick said looking
resigned I can't pretend I haven't been
expecting it expecting what Harry asked
you to come and find me said Nick it
happens sometimes when somebody has
suffered a loss well said Harry refusing
to be deflected you were right I've I've
come to find you Nick said nothing it's
said Harry who is finding this more
Awkward than he had anticipated it's
just you're dead but you're still here
aren't you Nick aside and continued to
gaze out at the grounds that's right
isn't it Harry urged him you died but
I'm talking to you you can walk around
Hogwarts and everything can't you yes
said nearly headless Nick quietly I can
walk and talk yes so you came back
didn't you said Harry urgently people
can come back right as ghosts they don't
have to Disappear Completely well he
added impatiently when Nick continued to
say nothing
nearly headless Nick hesitated then said
not everyone can come back as a ghost
what do you mean said Harry quickly only
only Wizards oh said Harry and he almost
laughed with the relief well that's okay
then the person I'm asking about is a
wizard so he can come back right Nick
turned away from the window and looked
mournfully at Harry he won't come back
who serious black said Nick but you did
said Harry angrily you came back you're
dead and you didn't disappear
Wizards can leave an imprint of
themselves upon the Earth to walk
apparently where their living selves
once trod said Nick miserably but very
few Wizards choose that path why not
said Harry anyway it doesn't matter
Sirius won't care if it's unusual he'll
come back I know he will I was afraid of
death said Nick I chose to remain behind
I sometimes wonder whether it ought to
have well that is neither here nor there
in fact I am neither here nor there
this passage is doubly sad because it's
clear that Nick has had to do this with
generations of kids who have lost loved
ones and felt certain that they will
come back as ghosts later feeling
betrayed when they realize they haven't
Snape's death though Snape's death was
shown in the Harry Potter movies I'd
argue that this moment felt much darker
in the books there were also a few
aspects of his death that were lost when
adapted to film for starters in the book
it takes place in the shrieking Shack
whereas in the movies it takes place in
The Boathouse an underground Harbor
located beneath Hogwarts the snake's
cage was rolling through the air and
before Snape could do anything more than
yell it had encased him head and
shoulders and Voldemort spoke in parcel
tongue kill there was a terrible scream
Harry's horse named's face losing a
little color it had left it whitened as
his black eyes widened as the snake's
fangs pierced his neck as he failed to
push the enchanted cage off himself as
his knees gave way and he fell to the
floor as Voldemort believes named to be
the master of the Elder Wand his death
was inevitable and so Voldemort makes
quick work of Snape ordering his pet
nagini to take care of business however
due to some clever camera work in the
films we never actually seen nagini's
fangs sinking into Snape's neck in the
film version we also see Voldemort use
some kind of slashing spell prior to
nagini attacking him
when Harry finally approaches Snape he
had blood flowing from his eyes ears
nose and mouth he's gurgling his last
breaths it's also way more drawn out in
the books we witnessed Snape plead with
Voldemort we truly felt for him however
in the film it felt as though it was all
over in an instant while the film felt
dark it didn't feel that dark Ron
getting attacked by brains deep within
the department of mysteries inside the
ministry of magic lies the brain room a
long rectangular room lit by low hanging
lamps the highlight of which is a tank
of oddly aggressive brains swimming in a
Green Solution unfortunately the brain
room love chamber space chamber and time
room were omitted from the films in the
books however there was a moment where
Ron who happens to find himself inside
of the brain room summons one of the
brains and nearly gets strangled to
death Ron no Harry did not know what
would happen if Ron touched the
tentacles of thought now flying behind
the brain but he was sure it would not
be anything good he darted forwards but
Ron had already caught the brain in his
outstretched hands
the moment they made contact with this
skin the tentacles began wrapping
themselves around Ron's arms like ropes
Harry look what's happened no no I don't
like it no stop stop but the thin
ribbons were spinning around Ron's chest
now he tugged and tore at them as the
brain was pulled tight against him like
an octopus's body
Defender yelled Harry trying to sever
The Feelers wrapping themselves tightly
around Ron before his eyes but they
would not break Ron fell over still
thrashing against his bonds what was
particularly dark about this moment was
that Ron's life was in danger and no one
was around to help him distracted by the
Dementors
Barty Crouch Jr.'s Dementors kiss Barty
Crouch Jr was a seriously questionable
individual however his actions in
Wizarding Society should certainly not
have waived his right to a fair trial
and sentencing after successfully
impersonating madamudi for an entire
school year Barty Crouch Jr is
eventually found out but does not
receive any kind of a fair trial
when we told Mr fudge that we'd caught
the Death Eater responsible for
tonight's event said Snape in a low
voice he seemed to feel his personal
safety was in question he insisted on
summoning a dementor to accompany him
into the castle he brought it up to the
office where Barty Crouch I told him you
would not agree Dumbledore McGonagall
fumed I told him you were never allow
Dementors to set foot inside the castle
but my dear woman roared fudge who
likewise looked angrier than Harry had
ever seen him as minister of magic it is
my decision whether I wish to bring
protection with me when interviewing a
possibly dangerous but Professor
mcgonagall's voice drowned fudges the
moment that that thing entered the room
she screamed pointing at fudge trembling
all over it swooped down on Crouch and
and Harry felt a chill in his stomach as
Professor McGonagall struggled to find
the words to describe what had happened
he did not need her to finish her
sentence he knew what the dementor must
have done it has administered its fatal
case to Barty Crouch In This Moment
Cornelius fudge abuses his power as
Minister and exposes Barty Crouch Jr to
a fate worse than death
Harry wishes he was with his parents in
the Deathly Hallows there is a
particularly sad moment where Harry
visits the graves of his parents this
happens in both the books and films
however the books did a much better job
of setting the scene and are able to
more accurately highlight the range of
emotions that Harry is enduring in this
moment in the books there is a
particularly dark moment where it's
revealed that Harry wishes he was buried
in the snow with his parents but they
were not living thought Harry they were
gone the empty word could not disguise
the fact that his parents mouldering
remains lay beneath snow and stone
indifferent and knowing and tears came
before he could stop them boiling hot
then instantly freezing on his face and
what was the point in wiping them off or
pretending he let them fall his lips
pressed hard together looking down at
the thick snow hiding from his eyes the
place where the last of Lily and James
lay bones now well surely or dust not
knowing or caring their living son stood
so near his heart still beating alive
because of their sacrifice and close to
wishing at this moment that he was
sleeping under the snow with them
umbridge's Centaur encounter in the
Order of the Phoenix Dolores Umbridge is
tricked into accompanying Harry and
Hermione into the woods where they run
into a herd of centaurs almost
immediately
umbrage unwisely insults them telling
them that they are creatures of near
human intelligence and filthy
half-breeds as a result the centaurs get
angry grab her and carry her off
over the punching many colored backs and
heads of the centaurs Harry saw Ambridge
being born away through the trees by
Bane still screaming non-stop her voice
grew fainter and fainter until they
could no longer hear it of the trampling
of hooves surrounding them
and while this does occur in both the
books and films only the books addressed
the aftermath after being taken away and
held captive by the centaurs for an
undetermined amount of time Dumbledore
ends up trekking off into the forest to
save her Professor Umbridge was lying in
a bed opposite them gazing up at the
ceiling then she had returned to the
castle she had not as far as any of them
knew I did a single word
nobody really knew what was wrong with
her either her usually neat mousy hair
was very untidy there were still bits of
twigs and leaves in it
it's never explicitly mentioned what
happened to Umbridge or what may have
happened with the centaurs but it can't
have been good
death of Charity Burbage in both the
Harry Potter books and films Michael
studies Professor charity Burbidge meets
a tragic end finding herself suspended
and tortured above a long table with
countless Death Eaters all around her
Lord Voldemort decides to torture and
kill charity in a cold-blooded manner
because of her muggle-friendly beliefs
and writings in the daily prophet and
while the films did include this scene
the books painted a much better picture
showcasing Charity's desperation as she
begs Severus Snape for help
the book also highlights the degree of
suffering that she endured Severus
please please silence said Voldemort
with another twitch of Malfoy's wand and
charity fell silent as if gagged not
content with corrupting and polluting
the mind of Wizarding children last week
Professor Burbidge wrote an impassioned
defense of mudbloods in the daily
Prophet Wizards she says must accept
these thieves of their knowledge and
Magic the dwindling of the pure Bloods
is says Professor Burbage a most
desirable circumstance she would have us
all mate with Muggles or no doubt
werewolves
nobody laughed this time there was no
mistaking the anger and contempt in
Voldemort's voice for the third time
charity Burbage revolved to face Snape
tears were pouring from her eyes into
her hair
Snape looked back at her quite impassive
as she turned slowly away from him again
Avada Kedavra the flash of green light
illuminated every corner of the room
charity fell with a resounding crash
onto the table below which trembled and
creaked several of the Death Eaters
leapt back in their chairs Draco fell
out of his onto the floor
and the Great Snake swayed and slithered
from his shoulders onto the polished
wood
and that's it for this video which
moments did I miss what do you think is
the darkest moment from the Harry Potter
books leave a comment down below also be
sure to check out Parts one and two
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign